So, we talked about merging but there's
another way that you can introduce your
changes into a branch. That's with 'git
rebase'. Now, I do want to have a
disclaimer here: when you use 'git rebase'
you are changing history, but that might
be your preference and might be what
your team chooses to do.
Let's talk about the differences. Say we
have two branches working here, this is the
'git merge' model and there's A B C and D
on one branch and E F on a separate
branch. Once we merge this branch into
the other branch, the way that's going to
appear in history is A B E C F D. So, it's
when the changes were made it -
it's accurate - but you might want your
history to be reflective of a different
nature you might want your history to
show when those changes were introduced
and make it more linear. That's when you
would use 'git rebase'. With rebase in the
same situation instead of merge it will
show the commits A B C D E F and their
logical order like I said it's really a
matter of preference and what your team
chooses to do. So, just be sure to check
with your collaborators and make sure
you know which one you're expected to be working with.